i'm sure it's a good documentary my my
problem with a lot of netflix
documentaries i found out fine nowadays
is that
it feels like they drag it out so much
yeah i remember because i
knew i knew the basic details of this
case because i've heard it from like
second hand
just hearing sydney listen to different
cases so i knew the case and i was like
okay
maybe i'll find out a bit more about the
details and then i watched 60 minutes
and the first episode was just
literally building up the hotel itself
and i'm just like i already know what
happens
who cares i don't care about it
this british couple was like staying in
the hotel i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
about a couple
let's get to the main facts please
that's been my big problem it was really
interesting because it was like the only
one that like
looked at like the online critics or
online like people were trying to solve
it in like a critical way
because there was another one that was
called like don't [ __ ] with cats
but i could not [ __ ] stand the girl
oh my god
it wasn't even that it was just like
we're just like internet nerds just
trying to like yeah it was like oh god
i i i understand that like you know the
modern cases a lot of
people but i like the way don't [ __ ]
with cats builds it up like it doesn't
even
it does it doesn't it they don't even
show you luca and mcnana's face until
the very end even though they usually
could have because they
want you to like see everyone's
perspective like that was involved in
this
that one was crazy and it would have
been so much better if they had just
replaced that woman with just a standard
narrator or something else like
i no no offense to the woman i just it
was it was
infuriating yeah yeah how she was just
talking about cats being murdered and
then she was like whoa
that was wacky and then we found him
killing other people
just just give you the facts i think one
one of the big reasons i could never get
into true crime or like
i i've never been able to fully invest
in it is just because it
it feels like to me i like i know it's
not unintentional but it feels like to
me it's
you you kind of view this as like a
fictional story you view it
as like an entertainment kind of an
entertainment based thing yeah
i remember watching don't [ __ ] with cats
and very
very fascinating story that's not that's
not what i'm saying and they had a
segment on this but
it just feels like it just for me it
feels a little bit
wrong or i just feel a little bit dirty
when i know that i'm watching this for
entertainment when
i'm i know that someone got [ __ ]
murdered and
that this is like some families lives
has perhaps
has been ruined by this and you know all
the attention is
on the merger and i know they did do
like a segment on you know how nobody
remembers the victim and that's just the
[ __ ] ugly truth
and that's why that's the big line for
me when it comes to like true crime and
watching like a good horror movie or a
good like
fictional story so i can't i can't like
wash away these feeli this feeling that
i'm just kind of like listening to this
like i'm i don't know what the right
word is but it's just like
i'm viewing this real life event this
real life tragic event
as an entertainment piece because that's
what it is it's an entertainment piece
and that's that's kind of like
why i've not been able to get into it so
would you prefer it then say
hypothetically if they like you know
properly go over like the
the family like i don't know what the
right way to go about it
it's just maybe there is no right way i
don't know i don't know if there is it's
just
it's just my mental vlog because like
you know i find something like for
example monster
fascinating because it's like a really
deep character study on you know what it
means to are you born evil or is
evil something you learn along the way
right but the reason i'm
you know the reason i can invest in it
is because i know it's a fiction there's
that's
that there's that barrier that i know
that nobody's like that moral barrier
right yeah it's kind of like i guess
telling you know story about wars and
stuff though as well right there's
tons of death in that and you know
that's just because you know
you know more often than not you just
used to tell stories about stuff that
had happened
in your life even though they have to
unfortunately i think at times stories
do have to be boiled down
in a way that will make people listen
yeah so it does almost feel like you say
like i mean i understand why the story
needs to be
said and why it almost does feel wrong
that it's entertainment but i understand
completely why it is
that way yeah like for human nature
we've always been telling stories
about horrific things yeah because
they're stories and
and the stories and you know sometimes i
feel you know it
it feels i don't know if wrong is the
right word but it just feels
weird to have it presented in a way that
is entertaining i will admit though the
the modern like gold rush of true crime
is getting a little bit weird yeah
like it's starting to feel a little bit
uncomfortable yeah how much stuff is
being milked and how much it's being
like
kitchen nightmares editing-esque yeah
stuff it's like
it used to go from these are the facts
of the case mary didn't know what was
coming
and then it came the point is if you
just present the facts of a case it's
boring it's [ __ ] boring and yeah i
especially feel this whenever
i watch like american news broadcast
versus like british news broadcast
because british news broadcasts are like
the most boring news broadcast
ever in america i remember the first one
went to america turned on the news and
it felt like i was watching a movie
yeah like i did ask didn't know
sometimes if i was watching the news in
america i was watching an episode of the
cops right yeah yeah yeah because
it's edited in the exact same way or
it's just like it's a little too
like yeah it's a little too i guess you
know and that
i guess kind of boils down to like that
whole genre of films of like
exploitation films right it's like it's
like some people find it really [ __ ]
fascinating yeah
well lots of the like that's not really
cool i also really like
documentaries because i like to figure
out i'm like alright who are they trying
to get me to root for
yeah what are they because it's someone
telling a story right and they've
carefully picked out all these
interviews carefully ask people
questions
to present it in a certain way and it's
fun sometimes i like watching it just to
figure out like
why are they trying to make me think
this way why are they trying to get me
to
get have this opinion the next character
it's just really interesting i guess
that's what made like uh tiger king so
good right
yeah yeah there's a video about like
quentin reviews about it yeah
about documentaries it's really good
yeah because i i think i think what made
me realize this is watching don't [ __ ]
with cats where
what was his name again wasn't luca
mendona luca menona
yeah yeah luca where
all he wanted was to have the spotlight
and what was to have the attention and
i remember i remember at the end
thinking oh he
he [ __ ] succeeded this is everything
that he wanted i don't know
this is literally like dark knight joker
he got a four-part netflix documentary
series dude
he was like he was the real winner out
of this yeah and
it just felt it just felt dirty to me i
don't know i was just like damn man
i don't know and yet yeah i guess when
that when his
sole aim was to get attention and then
he gets it that is kind of yeah
yeah i mean i just think it all just
comes from the human nature of like
looking at a car crash that you can't
look away from yeah yeah like you we
love to torture ourselves
one thing i do want to know is that
because i i wake up to this and i hear
a different story or like i hear i hear
a new
episode every time okay how how many
stories have you listened to
how many how many like how deep does the
true crime well go that's what i wanted
yeah because i feel like the
the the gentleman have only stepped into
the kiddie pool right
yeah yeah no i'm sick of it because i've
watched so many now that i can like feel
like the formula being formed yeah
yeah it always starts right they're like
you know timmy was a little different
but we never thought
that he would ever do anything like this
and then it'd be like it cut to the
victim and it's like
she was only good things the victim and
then cuts back to the thing it's like
and then something weird started to
happen at school and it's like all right
okay
he was okay he was weird right but like
they would never say this [ __ ] unless he
was a serial killer you know what i mean
like yeah
they find out is that they only remember
bad things everyone always says the same
[ __ ] about every serial killer it drives
me insane
is that true well after you've watched
like 10 dollars
you feel like you're going insane
watching more because you're like these
feel
all the same i feel like that with a lot
of especially like
again i'm making this sound like it's
[ __ ] film but like western crime like
i
it starts to feel like the same thing
but i mean i don't know um
[Music]
i'm sorry um i feel again
i mean with my series and like the one
in japan every case
isn't really the same in my opinion
because
i mean i don't know though at least i
literally have no i wasn't saying that
the case is the same it's how the
the documentary makers present the story
well the thing is like with true crime
podcast or true crime youtube videos
that i can see it's not always like a
documentary it's literally
literally just listing out the events
yeah i'd particularly like that yeah i
mean because to me it feels like i've
i've seen like
i've seen like top 10 lists of like the
weirdest crimes
top unsolved but we have top 10 deaths
caught on camera my favorites are the
top 10 breakdowns in courtroom cases
unsolved crimes yeah and like you you go
through one topic like what dictates
number seven over number eight like i
don't understand they're both horrible
and like i've you know i've heard of a
few and and you get to a point where you
know
it's like it's like asking people what
their top 10 anime is after after you've
seen enough anime you see you see that
you see the same cases yeah you know
what to say you know what everyone's
like
i love um sorry you know what the
mainstream anime are right yeah
that's how i feel like what are your top
10 crime cases
list them off chill style oh my god
number 10.
no do you want me to list like like off
the top of your head what
what are some of the ones that you stick
out to your mind well i literally have
like a bookmark
like list like this [ __ ] big on my
computer
true crime documentary like it comes to
mind like when you think
oh god legit like don't [ __ ] with
catchers is perfect to me honestly
honestly that was perfect uh besides
like the chick
the fact that like you know this is a
closed case and yet you feel like you're
it's still open like i don't know the
whole presentation i
love those videos where it's like it
presents itself it's like a really big
mystery
and then like you know they're like like
two episodes in and then they present
like what actually happened like the
very plausible very simple explanation
and then like
but some people don't believe that and
then it's like 30 more minutes of like
complete utter nonsense and it's just
like theories that don't make sense
[ __ ] it's like you already have the
explanation just accept that it's
[ __ ] boring like real life is
well because like weirdly enough you
didn't really like tiger king
no i actually which is weird because
like you'd think
that that the the you know the fact that
you know at the end of the day
it's a true crime right it's a true
crime story that's just a little bit
unique that any of those people got to
be filmed
yeah yeah yeah but like you didn't like
it i thought you'd like that
yeah i don't know why what was it that
like you didn't like about tiger king
that you did that you liked about
everything else i don't know
maybe i've just seen like seen and heard
so much [ __ ] up stories that like it
was just not entertaining to me
i was like oh yeah you've literally numb
just evolved i honestly i think it's
probably that
let's just stop watching a playground
argument just unfold but with guns and
tigers i think what i didn't like about
tiger king was the fact that i couldn't
believe these were real people
yeah like i thought i thought they were
playing like i deadass thought first two
episodes i thought they were playing a
character
i watched it all and i thought [ __ ] i
just wasted all my time
for nothing i'm just surprised how
popular it got yeah
i didn't expect i just really appreciate
especially
i'm rolling back to that youtube channel
criminal psychology just because
like it takes a lot of research to un
like to understand why this
interrogation is being played out the
way it is it's not just
question and answer it's like they're
trying to like create pressure for you
for you to [ __ ] just confess i guess
because you have a psychology background
it's like more
entertaining i feel like even without a
psychology background i think that
shit's just fascinating the way that
it's just presented they explain it like
you're five
and i don't know i like my heart starts
racing like the closer they get to
getting
to the getting that confession out yeah
to get in that confession i was like
here it comes yeah i've noticed that
there's like reaction youtubers
to interrogations there's people who
like watch interrogations and give their
thoughts
and
i don't imagine anyone like you know
doing all of that stuff i just like
interrogation that's like reacting to
public hanging
it's like whoa [ __ ] that just
happened it's like shocked
face uh underscore emojis
yeah we all have that png
it is bizarre that it has been like
commodified you know
yeah i don't know what the word is i was
like entertainment fight is that a word
i was like i was like there is i'm sure
there's a way i actually had no idea
that you guys had talked about the true
crime thing on your podcast so when i
uploaded the otaku killer video
like half my comments are like wow the
podcast was right about you i said
what i don't what joey what the [ __ ] did
you say
we called you out that's all right